[Musique]
ap a dû faire un procès vous n'irez
nulle part vous me rées nulle part
projet tombe à l'eau ce sont nos aînés
qu'il est noir
difficile de construire car pour jeunes
sans emploi sans espoir sans exploit je
ne nous sommes appelés à être des
leaders de demain
et chaque discours politique social
économique nous invite à prendre encore
à venir demain mais ils oublient ils
oublient qu'ils sont nomades war c'est
elle qui nous ont dévancé si le présent
que nous sommes sauf de l'objet du passé
que vous êtes ce que notre société ne
peut avancer
écoutez je ne suis pas venu au long
d'une jeunesse quémandeurs revendiquer
défaveur nous sommes une génération à
salé battante qui exige qu'on oublie
notre base pour apprécier nos idées nos
pauses et à la juste valeur voit de
jeunes qui boivent au qui fument vous
élève vous en parler mais voilà des
jeunes capables d'imposer vous et facile
aux pauvres sans trembler
s'offre et s'offrait conçoit des
porteurs de projet d'espérance que de
vire pernaut vide d'expérience être
jeune ambitieux chinois est 8e du sur
bâton secrétaires agents de vision de
liaison aux cèpes décideurs on ne traite
comme des nécessités notre jeunesse en
mal
jeunesse un même une carence en devenir
apprenez à lâcher le morceau pour qu'on
puisse mieux le tenir sinon vous et nous
on ira nulle pa
c'est pas con bateaux se sont opposés
qui sont énormes la jeunesse a des rêves
que l'âge adulte doit donner vie et
forme
à quai pour avoir volé blâmé pour avoir
volé rejeté pour avoir ravi en attendant
je saigne à mémoire de se poser tuer car
la jeunesse n'est pas une éternité
oui la jeunesse n'est pas une éternité
une sont conscients qu'un jour nous
avons vieilli mais nous souhaitons ne
pas être comme vous laissez moi parler
de se poser que l'on tue sans laisser de
traces laissez-moi parle laissez moi
parler de ce projet que notre système
gogo sans laisser aucune trace
nos pays doivent se développer la
jeunesse doit être sa cime arrêté de me
laisser penser catherine est un crime
alors my generation merci
[Applaudissements]